[Musique]
ça n'est pas une question d'être croyant
ou de ne pas être croyant notre héritage
chrétien n'appartient pas aux chrétiens
il appartient à tous les français et
tous les français doivent se sentir
légitime descendants de ceux qui ont
construit notre dame de paris et doivent
se sentir les d'une certaine manière les
enfants de cet acte de foi qui a fait se
dresser vers le ciel ses deux flèches
que nous avons vu s'effondrer lincendie
notre dame de paris a résonné dans nos
coeurs dans notre chair de façon
extrêmement profonde parce que ça nous a
permis de partager ce destin commun
passé et j'espère ce destin le futur
laurent wauquiez désir avec l'ensemble
des responsables de notre famille
politique a adressé à tous nos
sympathisants et adhérents un mail et
une aide pour demander aux adhérents de
la droit de participer à cet élan de
solidarité nationale
il est très beau que nous puissions être
rassemblées en effet rassemblé dans la
tristesse que nous causent la perte de
cette cathédrale ou en tous les cas cet
incendie qui a fait tant de mal à ce
patrimoine dont nous avons hérité très
beau aussi que nous ayons pu être réunis
aujourd'hui pour dire notre infinie
reconnaissance envers tous les sapeurs
pompiers de paris qui ont risqué leur
vie pour faire en sorte que nous
puissions vous voir cette cathédrale
encore debout et pour que nous puissions
maintenant la restaurer j'espère que ça
va nous permettre aussi de prendre
conscience de notre patrimoine de ce
qu'il représente dans le coeur des
français de ce qui fait que nous sommes
un peuple français que nous avons une
culture française que cette culture elle
est aussi universelle qu'elle rayonne
on se demande si après un malaise
parfois dans ce pays de parler de sa
propre culture parce que qu'est-ce qui
est au coeur du sujet si on s'aperçoit
que cet édifice appartient à tous les
français que nous avons une histoire
riche que cette histoire et les fait
évidemment de foi chrétienne
ce qui compte pour nous c'est
qu'effectivement on puisse reconstruire
notre dame dans sa splendeur à
l'identique du mieux qu'on peut
devant un tel monument nous avons besoin
de retrouver un peu d'humilité
je crois que nous ne sommes pas là pour
apporter comme le dit le président de la
république à un geste architectural
contemporain
pourquoi pas à ce monument historique
que nous recevons parce que on ne
cherche pas à augmenter une oeuvre d'art
qu'on reçoit restaurer notre patrimoine
c'est aussi faire vivre la france dans
ses savoir faire dans ces emplois dans
sa richesse et
mais comme vous ne l'ignorez pas en 1964
a été établi une charte de venise une
charte très importante qui définit des
règles en matière de protection du
patrimoine
est-ce que j'ai simplement voulu dire
c'est au fond une manière de voir aussi
le travail des politiques je crois que